Tiananmen Square this morning no sign of
an anniversary instead unprecedented
security and certainly no chance of us
stopping to ask anyone their reflections
on it all
it was a pivotal moment for China and
the consequences run deep even today
there's no figure for the number who
died on June the 4th 1989 hundreds
certainly some say thousands a peaceful
push for democracy was halted by
communist leaders determined to hold on
to power the defining moment at least
for those watching the pictures beamed
around the world was this one man's last
stand 25 years on that image and the
moment it represents has been entirely
airbrushed from history within China
what happened right here and just down
there in Tiananmen Square simply isn't
discussed the subject is so sensitive
we're not allowed to film anywhere near
the square activists academics even
relatives of those who died are being
detained almost daily and so to hear the
voices of those who are allowed to speak
and to protest you must travel a
thousand miles south to Hong Kong here
with relative political freedom they can
march to remember
many of those who survived escaped here
it was then a British colony
Kenneth lamb is a Hong Kong lawyer I was
stole startled then the whole street was
blood a quarter of a century ago he was
with the students in Tiananmen Square I
don't know how many of them was to
survive but I knew many of them thought
that a new Hong Kong Museum today's
generation of students who live outside
China learn what happened but
intriguingly among the visitors we did
find some from mainland China they
wouldn't talk but we're clearly
absorbing a version of history
unfamiliar to them Lee chung-yong
founded the museum in 89 he was in the
square he now wonders what China might
be like today if the protestors had not
been stopped and I can imagine that if
there's democracy in 25 years ago and
there will still be economic growth
there will be more better distribution
of wealth and there can be freedom
people would be happier
China's transformation these past 25
years is unquestionable cars now clog
the roads once claimed by the tanks the
Communist Party remains in power no one
mentions June the 4th and tank man to
this day his name in his fate remain a
mystery